well here in berlin police detained
about 100 people during protests against
the german government's coronavirus
restrictions
several thousand people are reported to
have taken part in marches around the
city calling for an end to the measures
including face mask mandates there were
scuffles between police and some
demonstrators who tried to enter
berlin's cordoned off government quarter
frustration evident in berlin
thousands of protesters against
coronavirus measures marched through the
city on saturday
with tense and violent scenes erupting
in some locations
here police had formed one of several
blockades to keep protesters out of the
capital's government district police
used pepper spray to force people back
after they pushed their way through
despite bringing in more than 2 000
additional officers to control crowds
the clashes still broke out
there were some attacks on police by
demonstrators
like bottles that were thrown and
physical assaults
at the moment we can report some 80
detentions
unfortunately four officers were also
injured so we can't say it was a
peaceful day of demonstrations in the
city
police later said more than 100 people
were arrested with dozens of minor and
criminal charges filed
ahead of the weekend the police already
warned there could be more protests than
usual in the german capital
many marching are against covet 19 rules
like mask wearing
this sign says do you have to buy basic
rights through vaccination
police are expecting demonstrators to
gather again on sunday
partially fueled by a newly founded
political party hoping to gain backing
from corona skeptics
you